marì marì marì marì marì marì se la zia
ti chiede qualcosa non sono stato io a
rompere il bicchiere di là non sono
stato io ok ok va bene
[Musica]
voglio sapere chi è stato a roma il mio
bicchiere è stato il cui ma guarda che
proprio una bella faccia tosta ma lo
sappiamo tutti che sei tu la maldestra
di questa casa è inutile che a pian di
miccoli ma guarda marì marì dai beni via
abbiamo di là tutti che si chiama carta
insieme con tutti gli altri
io devo finire di studiare ma come dai
che studiare da ora che sta tutti
insieme abbiamo prendere un gelato dopo
mi spiace dopo inizia documentario di
alberto angela e numero perderei per
niente al mondo
gli zii era detto che sto benissimo con
questi capelli
a me hanno detto che sono la più bella
della famiglia ma mi raccomando eh non
dire che te l'ho detto
comunque ho perso tre chili
solo io li ho persi 10 e ho raggiunto il
mio peso forma ideale beata te comunque
non so se lo sai ma ho fatto un servizio
fotografico
sì sì l'ho visto io invece ho iniziato a
sfilare per victoria's secret
fate i bravi voi due non litigano a una
tranquilla
da oggi anzi occupare la fascia mette le
thomas sky non voglio vedere costi borsa
gli ultimi al trono di spade
mari ma basta studiare sabato sera
metti giù quel libro usciamo un po dai
no io con te non ci riesco perché tu
sabato sera va in discoteca e mamma dice
che discoteca ci sta il diavolo ma non
vado in discoteca non ti porto in
discoteca non ci sono neanche più in
discoteca senti senti che programmino
top io e te da soli drink analcolico e
poi cinemino gli avengers che vi
piacciono tanto è avenger va bene va da
preparare brava brava vai da matti
l'ho convinta ed ai nostri stasera la
cuginetta si ubriaca in una maniera
assurda marini presso il tuo vestito
nero per favore sì va bene allora tu
presso mila sua borsa di paillettes va
bene ok è un'altra cosa e potente le
scarpe che indossava ieri sera le
balenziaga esatto non è che mi potresti
anche corda telo assolutamente no però
pensandoci bene se vi pensassi la tua
borsa di prada
potrei farci un pensierino
i do i do facciamo uno scherzo zia maria
allora sai che nei fissata con le
parrocchie di lana che c'è la sua
collezione
noi andiamo nei formati li prendiamo noi
buttiamo lì domani si svegliano le pro
impazzisce
ma rimasi a maria ma è vecchia ma
poverino può rimanerci sotto da un
momento ma chi è la mia cuginetta
preferita dai cosa hai fatto oggi a
scuola qual è la sua materia preferita
al via
guarda che graziosa questa fascia fa
molto riviera molto se il problema molto
antibes comunque proposito di vacanze e
prossima settimana vado alimenti ve
perché avete mani mi vedi che sono un
posto è stata in vista della maturità ha
detto amore ti porto rilassare quando
trovano poi vuole regalare la macchina
abbia mandato in paranoia perché quale
scelgo la lambo o la fiaba tu che
faresti scusa che cos'è la ferro ma la
ferrari no dai
guarda non lo so perché io dire
monopattino poverino mi dispiace fai
parte delle caste povera della famiglia
questo sorrisetto ecco chi tifa sentendo
niente con mark marco ancora tuo cugino
ma vuoi capire che non è normale mari ma
se vuoi secondo grado non c'è scritto da
nessuna parte che si segugi di secondo
grado
non si può portare questo è palese
incesto ma paese proprio vedo ma se ti
chiedessi una cosa no
ovvero quello di dover raccontare a
mamma che cosa c'era la sigaretta per me
che ho finite la cuginetta iniziato a
fumare è sembrava ieri che realta cosi
comunque no non fumo mi spiace sigarette
perché in compenso ho chiesta una bella
bomba avvenuta direttamente da amsterdam
a dai dai dai
la prima finestra che ci assumiamo
insieme si passino buon compleanno via
fanno tempo hai fatto di buono da
mangiare
la lasagna le partigiane con tale
famiglia giornata il tempo finalmente ti
fai vedere dove sono i regali vivai è
così purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere con
un commentino qui sotto quali di queste
cugini siete o quali di questi cugini
avete e se il video arriverà 60.000
laiche girerò la seconda parte quindi
spolli chat e tutti se non avete ancora
fatto iscrivetevi al mio canale eseguite
vi su tutti gli altri social facebook
in serata e tic toc vi mando un bacione
9 ci vediamo al prossimo bene
idiota
[Musica]